many people have seen The Matrix Neo is
going through the training program the
protagonist Morpheus is his his educator
his his teacher and the education
program only has one objective and so
he's walking through the city people are
going left and right he's he's bumping
into people going through like crowded
New York all of a sudden this woman in
in a red dress enters the frame morphus
is talking to Neo trying to teach him
something Neo were you looking at me or
you're looking at the woman in the red
dress and he says look again and he
looks back and it's agent Smith holding
a gun to his head and he says freeze and
then everything freezes in the frame and
he's like if you're not one of us you're
one of them and I see that as the
opportunities that we have to say no to
every day is like another woman in the
red dress and it's become a term that we
use internally right it's like it's a
woman in the red dress and the thing is
is that the more successful you become
or the more able you become the hotter
the woman in the red dress is but then
the better you get the bigger the
opportunities and that's where you have
not your hypothetical 10 but what about
your hypothetical 100 yeah